داعش هي أكثر من مجرد
أشباح هنا في غبار شرق
سوريا
ووقف القادة والأراضي الرمزية الأخيرة
في مسافة مطاردة تحت
جنح الظلام من
قبل المقاتلين الأكراد السوريين الذين
ضربتهم القوة الجوية للتحالف
ودفعوا للخلف باتجاه الحدود العراقية.
هنا ولكن أعلاه ، هناك
ميزة قاتلة للتكنولوجيا الأمريكية
عندما كانت طائرة هليكوبتر هجومية من طراز أباتشي
تجد هدفها ،
فهذه صور نادرة
للعمليات الليلية الجريئة التي
استعادت
مساحات شاسعة من الأرض من داعش
[الموسيقى] ،
من المذهل أن نرى مدى
بدائية الأدوات
في معركة ضرورية جدًا للعالم ، قم
بفرز المحلول الملحي الخفيف بالهاتف
والضمادات ، كيف
يبدو أن المقاتلين صغار السن عن
طريق
قصف القتلى الذين نجوا من
الجرحى الذين كانوا على متن الطائرة والذين يحتاجون إلى جراحة عاجلة ،
ويبدأون رحلة طويلة للحصول على رعاية أفضل من
خلال  يمكن لسماء الليل التي لا تزال تتردد
مع صوت المزيد من الوفيات
الكامنة في الأسفل في هذه
القرى المتبقية  أن يكون زعيم داعش أبو بكر
البغدادي
دافعًا عنه الموالون المتشددون والأجانب
وتفجير السيارات المفخخة في معركة
شرسة كما كانت من قبل
ولكن غير مرئي من قبل عالم اعتقد
الرئيس دونالد ترامب
عندما قال إن داعش هُزمت
معاقلهم حول
لا تزال قرية سوسا تسيطر
على ما لديهم حيث يجلب النهار
مجموعة جديدة من التحديات التي
تقترب من قذائف هاون داعش على السطح ،
يعلق قناصة داعش عليها.
المحتوى في هذه الحرب
القوة الجوية الأمريكية
وراء كل من تقدمها والكثير من
تدميرها ،
ومع ذلك فإن هذه القوة المطلقة لا يمكنها الإجابة على
السؤال الرئيسي حول
كيفية التعامل مع المدنيين الذين قدموا
لداعش المأوى والأفراد
على المدى الطويل
الصحة التي
تقول هذه العائلة إنهم خاطروا بها.  الاعتقال من قبل
داعش الذين فروا بعد ظهر هذا اليوم فقط
ولكن من المستحيل موازنة
احتياجاتهم الإنسانية المباشرة مع ما
قد يكون عليه تعاطفهم الحقيقي
وبالتالي يعودون مثلك  رمال
الآخرين إلى المعسكرات خلف خط المواجهة
حيث يكون تنظيم الدولة ضحية
ويشكل حاملو الأعلام المستقبلية المحتملين بئرًا من
المعاناة والكراهية التي ستشتعل
عبر هذه الطائرات لسنوات قادمة.